[Musique]
quand éric m'a appelé pour me dire il va
falloir que tu nous explique comment tu
as fait le job comment tu as choisi
d'être artiste comment tu es allé dans
ce métier artistique
je me suis dit mais en fait je vais
jamais réfléchi à ça c'était pour moi
une évidence une espèce d'inconscience
je sais pas comment vous expliquer mieux
j'ai eu toujours l'impression que
j'étais faite pour ça sert que pas un
seul moment je me suis posé des
questions alors venir ici devant vous ce
soir pour vous expliquer comment j'ai
fait ça a nécessité deux que je
réfléchisse
comment ça s'est passé dans ma vie
aujourd'hui j'ai 60 ans et et voilà
comment j'ai fait alors d'abord je vais
vous expliquer ce que je fais mon métier
artistique est assez spécial je suis
spécialiste des feux d'artifice et des
grands spectacles dits événementiel à
direction du très grand public dans les
spectacles populaires genre 14 juillet
ou aussi maintenant parce que j'y ai
réfléchi après à direction de
l'entreprise lorsqu'on s'aperçoit tout à
coup que l'entreprise peut avoir besoin
de moments spécifiques où le spectacle
l'artiste a besoin de rentrer en contact
élan vient à la deuxième intervention de
l'humain de la rencontre est toujours de
l'humain alors comme je vous le disais
j'ai pas réfléchi au départ et petit à
petit grâce à errer que nous avons
travaillé et je me suis dit bon
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui a fait que j'ai
fait ce job que je suis allé vers le
métier artistique que je fais
aujourd'hui alors premièrement force est
de constater que je crois qu'on est tous
obligés et orienté dès le début par sa
naissance alors d'un point de vue pour
qu'on va dire on va dire d'un point de
vue généalogique en tout cas lactique
l'on a c'est on sait pas de ça sort mois
il se trouve qu aussi loin que je me
propulse en arrière dès l'âge de 3 ans
je ne voyais pas les choses comme les
autres ployait je ne sais pas pourquoi
je vous explique il y avait un orage
dehors au lieu de faire comme la plupart
des enfants de mettre un oreiller sur la
tête
je sortais sur le balcon et je criais
c'est magnifique
mes parents avaient un tout petit
problème un petit problème avec moi
parce qu'ils aient ce gosse n'est pas
normal parce que voilà moi je trouvais
que les éléments en furie sam est elle
le paysage dans un état qui n'était pas
celui qui était habituelle et qu'on
avait bien voulu me
et dans l'état où il était normal de le
voir c'est à dire que d'un seul coup
j'ai trouvé ça incroyable quand j'étais
au bord du lac d'annecy où j'habite
je trempais mes pieds et je projetais de
l'eau dans le soleil est ce cette eau
qui projetait devenait immédiatement
soit des diamants pas forcément des
diamants parce que vous allez croire que
l'intéressé par l'argent mais en tout
cas quelque chose qui brille est quelque
chose qui emmenait l'esprit au delà de
ce qu'on est habitué à avoir c'est dire
que ce n'était plus de l'eau ce n'était
plus non c'était quelque chose qui me
propulse est dans un autre monde
la deuxième chose c'est que je suis né
dans une famille n'ont pas d'artistes
professionnels mais en tout cas de gens
qui aimait faire la fête et qui pour qui
tout devait être systématiquement
bossert qu'il devait y avoir une mise en
scène dans tout ce que nous faisions
je prends un exemple dimanche ne
passions pas à table chez mes
grands-parents temps que nous n'avions
pas fait ce qu'ils appelaient les
floralies
c'est à dire que on devait aller dans le
jardin avant entre la messe et les ailes
et le déjeuner
on devait aller cueillir des fleurs et
faire des bouquets de fleurs sur la
table alors nul doute que ça a dû
influencer
je vous raconte ma vie mais tout ça pour
dire que quoi qu'on fasse les uns et les
autres avant de faire le job
lorsqu'on veut faire dans notre vie il
faut bien prendre en compte tout ce qui
nous a été donnée que ce soit d'un point
de vue adn ou d'un point de vue
éducation je pense pas à révolutionner
le monde en disant ça mais je crois
qu'en tout cas ça nous apprend à nous
connaître
moi en tout cas ma vie n'a été qu'une
succession de bonheur quand je parlais
de mes trois ans cette année où il y
avait le fameux orages où je suis sorti
pour la première fois en dix ans c'est
magnifique il y avait aussi à annecy
un spectacle qui s'appelle la fête du
lac et qui à l'époque fêtait les 150 les
sentant pardon du rattachement de la
savoie à la france
pour l'occasion il y avait une immense
reconstitution historique avec l'ampleur
l'empereur napoléon iii à l'impératrice
des feux d'artifice partout et moi
j'avais 3 ans et je me disais mon dieu
si la vie c'est ça c'est absolument
magnifique
donc moi dans ma tête je me suis dit
plus tard j'ai envie de faire ça et je
vous assure qu'à l'âge
et quatre en cinq ans je n'ai plus
jamais dit autre chose à mes parents que
de dire moi je vais faire la fête a
alors ça je peux vous assurer que dans
des familles à 99%
on te dit mon garçon c'est très bien
mais passe ton bac d'abord
j'ai eu la chance une chance inouïe
c'est que mes parents ne m'ont jamais
dit cela
jamais jamais jamais il vendit bah oui
tu la feras peut-être tu verras nous en
tout cas on te fait confiance
et là ça c'est un mot auquel j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi maintenant j'ai quatre
enfants et et je n'avais pas réfléchi
pour moi mais je me rends compte que ce
qui m'a permis de faire mon job dans ce
fameux métier c'est la confiance
alors il ya effectivement une part
d'inné et d'acquis que je viens de vous
raconter mais un deuxième un deuxième
fait deuxième chose qui est extrêmement
importante c'est la confiance et j'ai
toujours eu cette confiance alors là il
s'agit de la confiance des parents mais
ça peut être après la confiance de ceux
qu'on rencontre et on en revient à la
deuxième ça me fait des interventions
qui m'a beaucoup plu parce
qu'effectivement je crois que deux lacs
de la rencontre n'est la structure la
construction de ce qu'on va devenir
on le sait pas à l'avancé moi c'est vrai
qu'avant de venir ici j'avais
l'impression d'être totalement
inconscient et de dire oui bah voilà
j'avais envie de faire ça je les faibles
allons-y
ben non en fait ce sont évidemment les
rencontres et la confiance que les uns
et les autres peuvent vous accordez au
fur et à mesure et s'il y en a un qui
vous donne pas et qui ne vous fait pas
confiance
eh ben on zappe et ça je le redis doit
jouer avec j'ai toujours ap les gens qui
m'ont merde je les ai toujours mis de
côté c'est peut-être préféré aussi
partie du jeu de mon code adn j'ai
peut-être cette chance j'en sais rien
le deuxième point après une fois qu'on
agrandisse et je me dis qu'est-ce que je
vais faire
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de faire bon vu
la structure familiale et
environnementales que je vous ai décrit
chez nous tout était joyeux jeu c'est
comme ça aimer les amis de mes parents
n'étaient pas forcément dans cet état
d'esprit et j'entendais toujours dire à
mon patron m'a dit de faire ça
machin est chiant enfin bref d'être des
tabous comme ça et la première chose qui
n'a aucun rapport avec le côté
artistique c'est que je me suis dit je
ne veux surtout pas avoir de chef
je ne veux pas rencontrer une autorité
qui m'empêche de faire ce que j'ai envie
de faire c'est ça qui après 2 qui a
prédominé dans ma décision de faire mon
job dans ce que je pense que je voulais
faire ça peut paraître bizarre alors je
ne suis pas contre l'autorité mais je
suis contre je suis avec la relation
c'est à dire que effectivement il ya
toujours une hiérarchie quoi qu'il
advienne moi aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
j ai la chance de diriger man
d'entreprise mais la hiérarchie elle se
situe ailleurs ce sont mes clients qui
décident
sauf quand je suis producteur de mes
propres spectacles mais néanmoins dans
la rencontre
il faut essayer de trouver en tout cas
moi j'ai toujours cherché à rencontrer
une relation constructive dans leur
encontre dans la découverte dans la
découverte de ce que sont les autres et
c'est ça qui m'a aidé à aller plus loin
pour étendre mon champ de connaissances
effectivement à chaque jour on apprend
et c'est ça qui est formidable mais il
ne faut rien refuser de ce qui peut
venir de l'extérieur
ensuite qu'est ce que je qu'est ce que
je veux faire je me disais moi à travers
ses spectacles il ya une chose qui me
plaît c'est que je je je vais créer le
monde différemment de ce que les gens
voient de ce monde
je vais vous montrer quelques photos et
on y reviendra après sur la partie
uniquement artifices parce qu'on fait
des spectacles qui vont bien au delà
bien évidemment j'ai demandé à 2 2 deux
photographes depuis trois ans de me
suivre pour écrire un livre et micheline
pelletier decaux et cyril bruno je leur
ai dit voilà ce que je voudrais c'est
montrer que à travers l'art en
l'occurrence ma spécificité c'est un art
éphémère puisque je donne non pas une
statue ni un tableau ni quelque chose
qui va rester mais je inocule dans le
dans l'esprit des gens un moment qu'ils
vont pouvoir s'approprier et ensuite
transformée à leur guise
moi j'ai envie de montrer des choses aux
gens tels qu'ils ne les voit pas et là
par exemple toutes les photos que vous
allez voir je vais les passer rapidement
ne sont faites avec cet objectif là j'ai
demandé aux photographes de de
photographier ce que vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de voir parce que
généralement on regarde les bombes et ça
pète
et ces événements c'est attirant mais on
n'en comprend pas le temps de regarder
la façon dont ça hitler l'environnement
et pourtant je peux vous assurer que
votre cerveau quand vous voyez nos
spectacles
que ce soit les miens au sommet de mes
confrères memories la façon dont vous
avez vu et c'est ce qui rend la vie si
belle et si merveilleuse j'espère qu'on
aide à à déprogrammer un peu le cerveau
de loutres hâte de votre travail de vos
tracas et de vos soucis
donc voilà par exemple j'ai
volontairement choisi des photos qui
montrent un site tel pour le voit pas
parce que tu y vas aller regarder le
reflet qui va aller regarder cette
statue cette statue n'est éclairée que
par les bombes de feu d'artifice
j'insiste bien pareil là c'est une
exposition de penan au château de
versailles ou d'un seul coup l'oeuvre
d'art et est inclus est d'ailleurs le
photographe devient lui même une oeuvre
d'art donc voilà je voulais pas son os
repassera d'autres après si vous voulez
ça c'est aux tuileries
c'est une autre façon de voir les
chaises vides c'est un jour il pleuvait
des trombes d'eau y avait aucun
spectateur on a tiré un feu d'artifice
pour 15 personnes
c'est la jam extraordinaire mais à
travers la photo finalement on arrive à
transmettre quelque chose d'autre donc
qu'est ce que je veux faire je veux pas
avoir de chef je veux être libre
une troisième chose aussi dans mon job
je me disais je veux avoir une qualité
de vie très important je crois que là
vous êtes ya beaucoup d'encore
d'étudiants certes on a tous envie de
faire quelque chose de précis parce
qu'on a des rêves
on a honte à ce très haut comme l'avait
dit thaler mais si ses rêves deviennent
quelque chose qui devient un handicap
pour pouvoir vivre pouvoir élever ses
enfants de ça moi je voulais avoir une
qualité de vie je voulais habiter à la
campagne profiter de la nature à les
monter dans sur les hauts sommets faire
du ski etc
enfin tout tout ce que vous avez et non
c'est tout à l'heure donc ça ça faisait
partie quand même des données du cahier
des charges que je m'étais fait que je
m'étais donné
et ensuite voilà ça c'était ce que je
voulais faire
troisièmement à quoi ça sert c'était la
question que je me posais parce que
quand on voit ça on se dit la priorité
la priorité des parents ce jeu vous ayez
un bon boulot pour gagner de l'argent et
a bien effectivement bien que les miens
et une confiance totale
c'était un peu compliqué il disait oui
comment tu vas gagner ta vie alors je
gagnerai magis si je suis utile à
quelqu'un en tout cas c'est ce que je me
suis dit et finalement en faisant des
spectacles au cours de mes études
parce que je faisais partie des bureaux
d'élèves et puis j'étais toujours celui
qui voulait organiser les réceptions les
machins et à je cite je me suis rendu
compte que je procure est l'occasion
unique aux gens un de se rencontrer de
discuter d'être joyeux et ce qui
revenait tout le temps à chaque fois que
je faisais des feux d'artifice des gens
venaient vers moi anglais c'est génial
ça me fait retomber en enfance
comme si le maître mot de la vie c'était
l'enfance elle va je crois que oui
finalement on revient à mes fameux trois
ans c'est le moment où je faisais ça
avec mon pied et mais jets d'eau je
revenais en enfance et cette enfance si
tant est qu'elle était heureuse parce
que tout le monde n'a pas cette chance
là cette enfance quand elle est heureuse
on a tous envie d'y retourner et ça nous
permet de supporter ce qui est
insupportable dans la vie parce que
c'est le fameux état de bonheur dans
lequel on s est peut-être un point
effectivement au milieu d'un no man's
land qu'on tente d'attaquer dans lequel
on va se projeter et qu'on ne connaît
pas donc je suis dit ça sert à quelque
chose
il fallait ensuite trouver un modèle
économique ça c'était important parce
que comment faire pour gagner de
l'argent etc sans il n'y avait pas
internet à l'époque
g je suis allé à la bibliothèque
municipale où j'ai pris le bus vous
parce que julie qui va être intéressé
par des fêtes la société s'appelle fêtes
et feux bonjour le programme
je fais la fête je fais des feux
d'artifice qui peut être intéressé par
ça à l'époque le uss vous il y avait des
véritable biographie dedans où les gens
se lâchaient complètement
il allait même jusqu'à dire ce qui
collectionne d'ailleurs génial pour les
cambrioleurs vous vieille halle et après
et y en avait un qui s'était c'était
invraisemblable et fiona qui disait moi
je faisais partie tel rallye et séraphin
et donc j'ai sélectionné à l'époque en
arrivé de monsieur mitterrand c'est le
moment où j'ai fait mon job n'y voyait
pas de rapport j'ai sélectionné 83
biographie et je leur ai tous écrite à
la main j'avais pas de machine à écrire
à l'époque pas d'ordinateur et s'y est
donc contact c'est pas trois personnes
que je de 9,1 je les connaissais pas
sauf que c'était des gens plus de moins
illustres puisqu'il était dans le who's
who eh bien figurez vous qu'il y en a
trois qui m'ont répondu le même chiffre
que trois qui sont aujourd'hui encore
mes clients adorent ça fait combien
d'années 36 ans les gens mes clients et
qui m'ont dit mais vous êtes
complètement fou mais on a envie de vous
suivre
donc c'est voilà la rencontre est le
maître mot c'est l'humain la confiance
en soi la confiance qu'on a reçu ce
qu'on est profondément soi-même d'air
qu'est ce qu'on a dans la tête et ne pas
le refuser
à aucun moment je me suis refusé de
faire ce que j'avais envie de faire
et alors qu'est ce qui a fait le déclic
parce qu'il ya quand même un moment
c'est bien gentil là maintenant je fais
la prospection dans l'autre sens qu'est
ce qui fait que j'ai fait le job barça
peut-être vous faire marrer aussi et
bien figurez vous que c'est l'amour
alors c'est encore
une histoire de relations humaines
puisqu'en l'occurrence il s'agit de mon
épouse qui un jour m'a dit mais je sais
pas quoi faire à l'époque je le
dirigeais une maison familiale de
vacances pour enfants en difficulté en
plus parce que j'avais ça me plaisait
mais jamais ces trucs là elle m'a dit
mais tu es fou tu devrais faire et ça je
reviens au maître mot c'est la confiance
que cette femme qui est qui était la
mienne m'a fait m'a donné envie de me
précipiter dans le vide
parce que c'était et et donc ayant écrit
à ses 83 personnes six dont trois m'ont
répondu eh ben j'ai créé ma société
à ce moment-là et quinze jours après je
faisais le lancement d'un parfum qui
s'appelle anaïs anaïs pour cacharel dans
les arènes de nîmes
je ne connaissais personne et à partir
de là bien évidemment le jump est en
permanence à faire tous les jours parce
que ça s'arrête jamais le jeu notamment
dans le métier artistique on recommence
tout le temps le job c'est rencontrer
rencontrer faire confiance alors j'ai un
petit côté peut-être un peu zinzin
c'est que depuis que je suis jeune
petits enfants j'ai toujours eu
confiance dans la providence je crois
que tout existe dans l'univers que rien
n'est impossible et que la part la plus
importante de la réussite se situe dans
le rêve car de tout ce qu'on a entendu
jusque jusqu'aux machines qui
construisent des trucs en 3d y'a pas une
chose sur cette terre en tout cas
d'humains qui n'est pas été conçu à la
base par un rêve qu'est ce qu'il soit
moi en l'occurrence il s'agit d'un rêve
artistique qui éclaire différemment les
choses mais toutes les choses
matérielles de la vie qui sont autour de
nous qui nous entourent font partie d'un
rêve et s'interdire de rêver c'est
s'interdire de réussir parce que la
réussite c'est évidemment certainement
un peu l'argent mais c'est avant tout de
se sentir dans un état de bonheur
moi je peux vous assurer que quand je
crée sein par exemple la voyez c'est un
éclairage qui n'a été fait que part du
feu d'artifice voyait la tour eiffel
en filigrane dans l'est quand vous voyez
ça il ya une espèce de satisfaction de
jouissance une attitude hédoniste
peut-être de ma part mais la recherche
la recherche de ce plaisir là c'est
participer à la création et je crois que
moi ce qui m'a donné l'envi d'aller plus
loin
c'est je suis dit si on est sur cette
terre je sais pas très bien pourquoi on
y est mais c'est de participer à l'élan
de création qui existe depuis la nuit
des temps à mon échelle un film puisque
moi en plus il se trouve que je je je ne
fais que des choses éphémères que je
transmets au gré du hasard auprès du
public qui a la gentillesse de venir
voir mes spectacles
donc aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé regardez
par exemple ça c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
ce n'est un éclairage micheline decaux
est allongé par terre en dessous les
arbres et éclairage que vous voyez des
feuilles on pourrait croire c'est en
plein jour ben non c'est le feu
d'artifice
c'est une autre façon de voir les choses
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui si on a envie
d'aller loin c'est de réaliser ses rêves
et de montrer le monde tel qu'on a envie
de le voir et pas tel qu'on nous demande
de le voir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]